morada para votar não peço desculpa que
o podia chave da mota e lhes dizem que
sou criativo e encontrar uma solução
para pôr a nota aaa a trabalhar não é
esta será a chave pois quando terminar a
moto por não conseguir estacionamento lá
fora e como toda viagem portanto é fácil
são os dois minutos previstos para
depois seguir viagem e portanto decidi
trazer esta mota porque ela faz parte de
um projeto que estão a desenvolver há
cerca de um ano
chama-se pela estrada fora poderão ver
tu viu aqui
num neste genérico é encostou
transformar a minha viagem por portugal
em diferentes regiões
trás-os-montes e minho alta extremadura
foi a região onde iniciei esta viagem e
que tem um objetivo muito claro que
interessa no particularmente na área
profissional que é a questão da
identidade identidade de uma pessoa
a identidade de uma região e identidade
de um país porque aqui se preocupa e
expira desenvolvendo este trabalho esta
viagem em que eu levo nesta um chinelo
máquina fotográfica cadernos onde vou
captando as imagens que mais me
interessam conversa com pessoas que está
presa por um fio
elas sabem fazer aquilo mas quando
deixarem de fazer muito provavelmente
mais ninguém dará continuidade a essa
essa arte fizeram durante toda a sua
vida
chama se a isso a inspiradora através da
obra de antónio campos que é e grafia de
salvaguarda e portanto surgiu esta é uma
das idéias que desenvolvi com falar
vocês aqui
durante este tempo é eu pego na mota
levo essa viagem sozinha ou viajando
pelas aldeias estão as filas e também
pela cidade dentro da cidade existem ao
sair a custo zero que por exemplo esgoto
em milão idéias dentro dela porque dá
uma cidade feita constituída por cujos
habitantes são migraram de
trás-os-montes e minho o algarve
alentejo durante décadas e acabam por
formar essa cidade com uma diversidade
tão grande e cultural das nossas aldeias
por exemplo aqui na estrutura que deus o
natural e portanto assim mais à vontade
nessa viagem
novos locais eu procuro acima tudo
mostrar aquilo que de alguma maneira
está caindo no esquecimento
quero paisagens que é na parte da
gastronomia nas histórias das pessoas
aquilo que elas fazem diariamente que
fizeram durante toda uma vida sem contar
essa história de uma forma enfim toda a
nossa história que gerações e gerações
construíram isso é essa identidade é de
alguma maneira entanto na medida em que
nós somos um país tenha uma moeda pelo
escudo passamos a ter o euro fizeram os
pássaros a fazer parte da união européia
portanto é um coletivo de que é possível
minha opinião conseguimos preservar na
mesma a nossa identidade para que de
alguma maneira nos apresentemos ao mundo
de uma forma genuína com o adm ser
indagou
eu acho que qualquer assim como maçarico
que tem mais a ver com minha área
a obra de arte é é a china que consegue
ocupar um lugar na história da arte
aquela causa espanto e qualquer serviço
tudo que nós possamos desenvolver no
nosso país nós compreendemos a nossa
identidade
nós fomos sensíveis e se passarmos para
a preservarem e valorizarmos estou certo
por exemplo jogar muito melhor e
prometem um futuro mais promissor porque
conseguimos apresentar nos jornais pelo
mundo com os nossos serviços produtos
sabe criar e vamos causar espanto porque
optamos por esta linha está a a empresa
esta esta idéia de criarmos público com
base naquilo que nos rodeia tv com a
nossa investigado
esse trabalho tem se desenvolvido também
fazem não consigo fazer a viagem fácil
porque eu descobri nos locais google
conversado com pessoas voando tam de
fazer um mundial que depois
a filmado jovens entre eles dois que
fazem parte dessa equipa que vão
construir as e assim transforma o tal
episódio publicado argel para poder
mostrar a todos os que gostam desta área
e assim o mundo também mostra um peixe
tem valores que tem uma tradição tem
cultura tem uma identidade própria e tem
muito mais rodado que o escândalo tem
vindo a ser feito am nos últimos anos
não só as normas da união europeia é
evidente que temos de respeitar para
fazer parte dela mas que é possível nós
manter um lugar próprio também e
afirmamos com outros homens que
assumiram os efetivamente é podemos ser
tão bons como outros países facto
estavam sou com com todos os gráficos
nível econômico com as plantações no
máximo o desenvolvimento em todas as
áreas
um exemplar além disso esta capital da
procura das tradições de desmobilizar eu
a par disto o senhor desenvolver um
projeto que é o cinema tropa que é um
festival de cinema
o gráfico onde eu vou é uma escolha de
cassetes com gravações antigas e as
pessoas tenham que levaram com as suas
próprias câmeras 80 90 e que esses
momentos familiares e é eu tava cuidar
um novo ciclo dodô um dos ciclos de
silval que o ciclo do cinema de filmes
de família é que nós ram é quase que
fazer uma viagem
passado e encontraram sangue momentos da
história tão importante para que as
futuras gerações consigam compreender as
diferenças que nosso país a nossa
cultura nossa identidade tem sofrido ao
longo de décadas
isso torna uma pessoa muito lixo
fui porque faço o que eu gosto
o tempo com aquilo que tenho com o texto
o projeto é parte pra eu desenvolvo com
base naquilo que foi isso exactamente a
embaixadora todas é ter lei a
embaixadora do do projeto quando ela vai
para onde eu como patrocinadores quer
pessoas quando convém à moda passar
ordens em um corda que temos uma
história temos uma identidade temos
muitas cenas da montagem foi feita em
portugal em 1975 ela tem 38 anos
destaque ainda para as curvas o viram só
taxados espanhol sam é um pequeno
detalhe é tão boa que tem uma chave de
fendas e aqui é a palavra do desenrasca
dizer que não tem tradução não é
temos nosso fato o aumento ou mal iria
tentar é criar um monte
durante 15 minutos em que eu vi que não
tinha a chave e tentar desenvolver uma
linha de produção até encontrar uma
chave para resolver o problema eo
português bonito e fez assim e está
feito
mota está pronta para dar essa
felicidade na altura começaram se
associa pra mim quero dar fosse dado aos
outros e para fugir aos outros nos
braços o que tenha que é uma canção é os
meus amigos dos pais
as pessoas não são próximas mas quando
eu te encontrar 123 os passos que forem
necessários para ir ao encontro de
alguém aí e dar publicidade com as casas
o ritmo e isso enche a alma e quando
fácil fácil curaçao francamente não
quero nenhuma com fundo uma madre teresa
qualquer que seja
eu achei que com
nós temos esta consciência da
solidariedade
estou certo com extremos uma cidade
muito mais
é justo mas é mais equilibrada e com
isso conseguimos ter um lugar mais
saudável e cheio de se dar conta minas
nós temos um grupo de cinco pessoas
quatro muito felizes de uma triste eu
creio que essa de alguma forma será
contagiada com essa sociedade fica muito
mais feliz em quatro estiverem muito
triste e um final feliz
a etapa será um pouco mais difícil mas é
possível que este consiga contaminar os
quatro
estou triste e uma que eu falo é que o
que tinha de fazer
eu não faço muito importante porque em
casa branca tem tentado começou a aas
sinais de algum das taxas todas de tudo
é que o como durante esta viagem se ter
algum cuidado e até o que eu queria
fazer em vez de 12 horas com 30 no
ginásio para o goleiro victor essas duas
horas ou três por semana
é um trabalho solidário aqui eu tenho o
nome de olhar sem abrigo olhar cheio
abrigo é é um projeto em escala mundial
porque porque uns aí pegaram em 17 mais
na vida da língua e refeições servidas
refeições e vi que já estava bem
organizado
a faca já existem muitas instituições
que neste momento atuam nas ruas de
lisboa para associar um estômago
muitos dos sem abrigo que existem na
cidade então pensei por que não dar lhes
mais qualquer coisa que eu sinto tão
úteis no projeto e já agora eu enquanto
criativo conseguir combinar as imagens
que uns vão trazer uma máquina destas
assim uma máquina despertável onde eu
entrego sempre boa
jaílson e projetar três anos neste
momento olha achei abril já apresenta em
não em todos os continentes mas há o sul
da américa as capitais já têm as
máquinas para passada enviei mais cinco
para apenas o outros madrid tem uma
equipe tais e acho que fazem saber se as
máquinas do chipre faz o seu dia a dia
na cidade
agora querem passar a máquina
fotográfica a cidade segunda sua
perspectiva depois móveis máquinas e
será feito uma organização dessa todas
essas imagens para que depois passarmos
uma especial tem uma uma escala
internacional para dar uma maneira
conseguimos sensibilizar as pessoas para
a necessidade de sermos solidários com
isto vejo aqui 40
parece que o voo está realmente passar
carreira e eu vou terminar com um
pequeno vídeo que as peripécias que
acontecem muitas das vezes na viagem do
tema estrada fora e passou por goiás
troquei as duas rodas da macau pelas
quatro patas do burro espião é um dos
habitantes do museu eco do freixial um
museu vivo que constitui a vida rural do
princípio do século 20 vamos fazer uma
disputa já acho que ela vai ficar com o
gol a equipe baiana